hello everyone and welcome to another
very exciting game between yeppo and
magnus it's from the 2010 world blitz
championship in moscow uh some seven
years after the
previous game that we've checked or let
me just check real
uh yeah seven years after that uh
under a world championship under 14
years
and it's a really really uh tough
competition here so now let's check it
out it's a blitz game we're not going to
overanalyze it but you know some of the
positions that are arise are really
really exciting and we're going to
discuss them a little bit and there's a
really really
complicated positive video moment so you
know sorry about giving you such hard
time on a sunday but you know it's it's
a very nice position uh so let's check
it out uh nipple with the white pieces
opens with e4 uh and this is their fifth
encounter all together so here we have
g6 by magnus going for the modern
defense or the robust defense
knight to f3 knight to f6
attacking the c4 pawn and now knight to
c3 defending and now the immediate d5
magnus strikes in the center he captures
on the e5 knight captures and bishop to
c4 your knight is attacked so you have
three options here really you can play
c6 defend the knight you can attack the
bishop with knight to b6 or you can just
capture on c3 and double white spawns
but white doesn't really
mind as you will have very nice support
for this d4 push if the sharper the g7
will be played and of course it will be
since the pawn is already on g6 so the
shot to g7 and now uh nipple doesn't go
for d4 right away he first castles here
and magnus takes this opportunity to
play c5 and now grab
control over the d4 square
so here we have rook to e1 and magnus
just castles and now nipple plays knight
to g5 and it is now as of move 9 that
this position has never been reached
again it's quite an exciting one uh what
is uh
uh black to do here so magnus just
continues with knight to c6 there is no
uh threat here that you don't have to
worry about ideas like queen to f3 going
after the spawn here you can just play
e6 or whatever and it's perfectly fine
uh so instead we have bishop the a3
going after this c5 pawn uh and now uh
well now comes queen
a5 attacking the bishop but this is
already a very very interesting position
because here black can play e5 it's a
very tricky move the knight is
undefended on g5 so you don't really
have a good option here so you can
either go back with the knight and then
black plays b6 defends the c5 pawn or
you could actually go for this knight
captures an f7 as it is a blitz game
then let's say bishop captures on c5 now
the two bishops are very strong you're
gonna capture on f7 for example queen c7
bishop captures queen captures and uh
you get this position but black really
has nothing to worry about here he has
two bishops for the exchange or rather a
bishop and knight for the exchange uh
this will be good for uh for black so
instead after bishop to a3 we have queen
to a5 now defending and attacking the
bishop here and nepo defends it with a
queen to c1 so still this pawn on d2
has not been pushed anywhere we have e6
now
and now comes knight to e4 putting
pressure on the c5 pawn and only now
magnus defends it with b6
so now you're ready to play bishop to b7
you could also play bishop to a6 if you
want to get rid of white's light square
bishop
and now we have bishop back to b2 nipple
sort of prepares this d4 idea
magnus plays bishop to a6 once the trade
of the light square bishops and now
captures captures and now plays a4 still
uh d3 would be uh very interesting here
because then black c4 can be met with
the d4 but here after a4 magnus now gets
the opportunity to play c for himself
and c4 is a very very interesting move
here your bishop on b2 isn't uh really
going to be useful anytime soon and you
will have problems executing this d4
idea now because the d3 square is very
nicely guarded by
black's pieces also if the rook comes to
c8 it could be could be even better
but magnus decides to bring the rook
into the game first he plays rook after
d8 and now nipple of course plays d3 so
for some reason uh
c4 was not played c for now and now of
course d4 but now it's much different uh
the bishop still uh
doesn't have a way of entering the game
probably the queen will move and then
we're going to shift the bishop to c1
and then use these dark squares so
knight to e7 now the knight can be
shifted to d5 the c3 pawn is very weak
so we can try to attack it queen to e3
and now knight to d5 putting pressure on
the pawn attacking the queen we have
queen to g3 and now rook ate the c8 so
adding another defender now the queen
can also be shifted back into the game
somehow
uh and uh nepo finally plays bishop to
c1 and the bishop is now ready to join
the action so rook to d7 you know that
the bishop is gonna
join the action on the dark squares so
you want your rooks and light squares
bishop to g5 and now queen to a5 again
putting more pressure on this c3 pawn uh
so uh nipple has to decide how to
continue here he plays rook e to b1 with
the idea of shifting the rook over to b5
to really get rid of that queen also
possible is maybe just the h4h5 maybe
even h6 the knight to d6 a knight to d6
is a possibility the queen nicely covers
that you could put some pressure on
black's position then maybe shift the
knight over to b5 but um you know it's a
a very rich position for a blitz game in
the in the actual game rook e the b1 was
played here in april wants to play rook
to b5 uh and now f5 uh asking what do
you play here now if the knight moves of
course the c3 pawn uh will hang but you
could still play knight to d6 for
example if rook to f8 now we play knight
captures on c4 and the black plays queen
captures on c3 but magnus really
wouldn't have anything to worry about
here uh the knight is attacked you're
offering a queen trade queen three a
queen trader um works really in black's
favor so let's say 95 and now rook c7 uh
here just guarding the queen uh if a
queen trade occurs even knight captures
on c3 this is a very very good position
for black so instead nipple goes for
rook to b5 right away chases away the
queen queen a6 and not knight to d2 goes
after the c4 pawn
and uh well just uh nicely regarding
that c3 pawn so you don't have to worry
about black capturing it so magnus goes
queen to b7 and now we have rook uh beat
uh back to b1 uh if you go something
like a5 which seems like uh a move you
wanna play queen c6 and that rook being
on b5 is a problem once you move it then
b5 a6 is coming and the black's position
on the queen side really consolidates so
instead after queen to b7 we have the
immediate rook b to b1 and now magnus
sidesteps this of course queen c6 we
have bishop to f4 now hoping for this
trade knight captures on f4 but this
knight
is a very very important um
uh you know piece in the position just
you know in the center of the board
controlling many squares so rook to e8
preparing maybe e5 in some lines and now
rook to e1 by nipple we have a6 now
preparing b5 uh and finally h4 now
nipple can play h5 h6 and so on so here
b5 by magnus a captures on b5 a captures
on b5 and now the ship to e5 putting
pressure on
uh carlson's dark square bishop uh we
have bishop captures rook captures on e5
you could capture with the pawn or with
the queen but here you capture with the
rook and then you're gonna play rook
eight to e1 this uh pawn on e6 is a weak
pawn weak backward spawn so you really
wanna
put some pressure on it uh so queen to
d6 and now if the the rook moves you can
easily trade queens here and rook eight
to e1 uh we have rook d to e7 adding
more defenders here to the pawn and now
nipple just continues pushing with h5 so
here rook to g7
and uh
you don't have to capture or push or
anything you could just play knight to
f1 and try and improve your position a
little bit maybe knight h2 knight f3
but
even if black captures you can play
queen f3 and this is just going to be a
problem for the rest of the game however
we have the immediate h6 from nipple rug
g back to e7 and now as you don't really
have um all that much to do here with
with the rook rook to b1 putting
pressure on the b5 pawn so queen to a6
defending the pawn uh and now comes rook
b back to e1 asking magnus okay what do
you do here do you repeat or do you want
to try and push this
so magnus decides that he is going to
push he plays queen to a3 now puts
pressure on the c3 pawn and this is the
position i was talking about it's um a
very static position not a lot to push
for here but there is one move that
really uh makes the position more
interesting uh so feel free to pause the
video here and figure out what would you
play here in this position while i give
you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
uh well very awkward move to play and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show it's actually knight to f3 but
we're gonna discuss that a little bit uh
after i show you what uh nipple played
nipple went for queen to g5 this is also
very interesting but knight to f3 uh
really makes it a problem for black to
continue playing this game because okay
you can capture the c3 pawn with the
knight or you could capture it with the
queen uh but uh neither really works for
black if you capture with the queen then
we have this very exciting rook captures
on e6 that's the problem and the
the reason it works is because of the
pawn here guarding the g7 square so
another very good example of how just
pushing that pawn restricting the black
king can do wonders for you the thing is
now after rook captures rook captures
and rook captures you have queen to b8
with check and now you don't have this
square for the king uh you have to go to
f7 and after king to f7 now knight g5
check and now check this out king to f6
you want to keep an eye on the rook
we're going to play queen to d8 with
check rook to e7 and now knight captures
on h7 with check king to e6 now we're
gonna go back knight the g5 check and
now after you play king to f6 the only
move now we can even play knight to e
for check and win black's queen so as
you can see queen captures on c3 uh is
bad on on many many levels another thing
you could do after knight to f3 is maybe
capture with the knight because well
if you can why wouldn't you uh the
problem here is that after knight to h4
there are really so many threats here
you can't move the knight because the
queen hangs knight captures and g6
always very dangerous and here black
would really struggle for moves for
example f4 to get the queen away from
the g file uh but still we're just going
to play queen g4 and now if you bring
the queen back to try and help out with
the defense of the pawn for example now
you you're dead lost here just captures
captures and captures with check king h8
now queen f6 check and after king here
you can just play rook captures on e6
and there is no good move here for black
of course the rook cannot be captured
queen g7 will be checked made if capture
with the queen of course we still
capture and you can't even capture
because of checkmate so there is no move
you can play here
uh so after knight to f3 uh black would
really have to struggle to find the move
and this knight to f3
is basically how you
uh
how how you make progress here and how
you
will just uh
force black to figure out a different
way into the game probably queen back to
d6 but now we shift the knight to g5 and
we've improved our position drastically
removed activity from the black queen
also the c3 pawn is still defended and
we can continue making some progress
here so but again this is a blitz game
this is just for you guys you know
enjoying your sunday of course no one is
expecting anyone to find such things in
a blitz game so queen g5 by nipple and
now we have knight captures on c3 queen
captures loses by force because now the
queen attacks the rook here so just rook
captures on d5 wins on the spot
so uh first knight captures on c3 magnus
now wins this spawn and maybe he can
play b for b3 and create a pass pawn and
win the game this way so knights to b1
nepal offers a trait here attacks the
queen also the knight here so knight
captures rook captures and finally b4 so
now magnus is getting a pass pawn uh
regardless of
what white plays so here we have d5
now you can't capture because the e7
pawn is covered by the rook and by the
queen but what you can play is b3 this
is what you want to play either way and
now of course uh
the queen also helps out with the
defense of the rook on e7 so c captures
on b3 and now magnus just advances the
pawn to c3 now with the idea of c2 you
don't really have a win yet as the rook
and queen are covering the c1 square so
you're gonna have to do something about
this and nipple plays d captures on e6
uh again it's a blitz game and the rook
captures an e6 would probably offer more
chances for white because now for
example c2 we're going to play rook c1
and after rook captures we're going to
play d captures on e6 point being that
you can't really capture on
on e6 you do not want to allow this
queen to d8 to check if you remember the
g7 square is not available to the black
king so we'd probably see something like
queen to d6 but now rook to e1 and
there's really nothing better now for
black
because the white now has two two past
pawns you would have to go for this
trade to eliminate at least one of them
but then for example queen to d8 with
czech king to f7 now queen to c7 check
picks up the pawn on c2 king of six
queen captures in c2 and now you're up
upon in a queen and pawn in game with
this beautiful past b pawn so black
would have to struggle here
however after c3 d captures on e6 was
played now magnus plays c2 rook to c1
and now we have rook to c7 uh adding
another defender here so now the queen
can move uh and also magnus still
waiting for this uh queen captures on b3
and now nipple plays rook back to e1 and
this is very interesting another uh
really move that really really improves
white's position is just rook to d5 the
point is
black never wants to move a
rook from the back ring because then you
get problems here along the back rank
pawn still covers g7 so you would really
struggle uh to find a move here uh for
for uh for black but okay it's a blitz
game rook e back to e1 was played and
now magnus plays queen to b2 uh probably
uh to guard the f6 square because queen
f6 could be very dangerous if this pawn
blocks the the rook's defense of the of
the
g7 square uh but it is possible to
capture for example if queen captures
queen f6 we can simply play queen to c3
and there there are no problems here we
offer a queen trade we've eliminated one
of the attackers but magnus plays queen
to b2 first and now we have king to h2
getting the king away from the back ring
queen captures on b3 now and queen to f6
now threatening checkmate here but now
queen to c3 of course uh defending uh
against any dc e7 threats and offering a
queen trade so magnus uh nipple could
postpone this by playing some like queen
to g5 then the game continues but uh he
decided to trade we have rook captures
on c3 and now rook to e2 just going
after this pawn we have rook eat the c8
magnus defense is spawn and now e7 uh we
have king to f7 and now we have to
remove one of the defenders of the c2
pawn so e8 queen this comes with check
we have rook captures and now rook e
captures on c2 we have captures captures
and now after all this madness we have
the rook component game with uh
completely equal material so g5 by
by magnus and now we have rook to c7
with check of course we have to guard
this pawn so king g6 rook c6 check king
the h5 now
and now black can play some like rook to
g8 g6 and then pick up the pawn so king
to g3 now comes rook to g8 and rook to
f6 now attacking this pawn so f4 check
by magnus king to f3 and now rook the g6
so magnus is definitely winning upon
here but even if you just trade here
captures captures and king kg4 king
captures an h6 this is still a draw yeah
even though you you're up a pawn uh but
rook
f7 was played going after this pawn but
now just king captures an h6 we have
king to g4 now comes rook to b6 so
rooks are still in the game now and the
black is up upon so could still be very
dangerous but it's very hard to make
progress here we have rook to f5 going
after the g5 pawn and now rook to b2
we're going to have a a trade here rook
captures on g5 rook captures on f2 rook
to h5 check king to g6 and now rook to
g5 with the check and he was in this
position on move 63
that nipple and the magnus agreed to a
draw as there is no way to make progress
here even if black were to you know get
out of check king e6 we're going to
capture here you're going to capture
here this is still of course a dead draw
and no point in playing this so really
an exciting one their fifth encounter
altogether uh magnus was better in the
uh in the beginning but then nepo really
had a lot of chances throughout the game
but you know that can only be exploited
if it was not
a blitz game and it was
uh so uh two blizz games were played in
this tournament between these two
gentlemen both ended in a draw uh i
think i showed the the first one uh you
know some time ago so i didn't want to
show it again uh but as you guys always
enjoy this here are the standings of the
world blitz championship 2010 just
check how they uh compared in those days
so the tournament was won by levon
arunian with 24 and a half points
followed by them or a job of with 24 and
then magnus carlsen in third place with
twenty three and a half and then as you
can see what
is peter swiddler pablo ellanov
alexander grisham ralph
and only then ian nipponishi with 18 out
of thirty eight maxima shallow graph
sergey mavsesion dimitri andreikin boris
grace of borisov chenko fabiano caruana
and ruslan ponomariov uh so there you
have it the standings of the 2010 world
blitz championship uh and the fifth
encounter between magnus and nippo all
together so we're gonna
continue in this style up until the the
world chess championship match but of
course we're gonna cover other things as
well and i am preparing the next big
saga i'm waiting for three books to
arrive that i will be using for this and
only then will i be announcing uh which
saga it will be uh but yeah that's the
game i hope you guys enjoyed it and that
you found that slight improvement in the
position with knight to f3
i would like to thank marshall farrier
jean-francois bond uh mathias bollinger
uh oliver nichols and the hoodie guy for
your contribution to my channel thank
you a lot i really appreciate it as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon continuing some more
games between these two gentlemen
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world so thank you all i will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your sunday